[Musique]
twitter
où
[Musique]
ou lé clip it hot in derrière
vous en saurez combien
onze espèces blue est la dernière du
genre vous ne pourrez jamais la capture
et vous savez peut-être qui pourrait
nous aider
une mission de sauvetage qu'est ce qu'on
risque il me connaît bien avec moi tu
sais que tu peux pas rester ici
rappelez-vous somme toute c'est toi ils
m'ont menti
l'homme qui a prouvé que les raptor
peuvent obéir vous ne vous êtes jamais
demandé combien de millions vaudrait un
prédateur dressé ils vont vendre table
où ils ont d'autres projets pour aller
c'est quoi cette chose mon cri c'est la
créature la plus dangereuse qui ait
jamais existé
je propose qu'on arrête ce délire
[Musique]
est ma mère tu pense comme moi on a du
béret la puissance génétique on ne peut
plus faire marche arrière
[Musique]
l'eau
si je reviens pas
n'oublie pas que c'est toi qui m'a
demandé de venir ici je vais m'en sortir
ces créatures étaient là bien avant et
si on n'y prend pas garde ils seront
encore là bien après bienvenue à
jurassic world
[Musique]